[Music]
nothing motivates me aside from eating
and sleeping I lie in my bed all day not
on my computer not on my phone not doing
anything I just lie there thinking
what's happening to me I would say that
you are this is not a diagnostic comment
and I don't know enough about you to
provide that sort of information but I
would recommend that you see a therapist
and be screened for depression because
that's what it looks like to me and I
would say that if it's depression you
should do something about it because
depression is very hard on people it
produces a lot of stress hormones like
cortisol and and that can hurt you it
may be you know if it's only been a
couple of days I wouldn't worry about it
but if it's a chronic pattern then you
should go talk to somebody even your
family doctor you know and there's
always the possibility that a low dose
of an antidepressant might be worth
trying you know in a month if it fixed
you but I would say don't don't stay in
that situation man go find out do
whatever you have to do to get out of it
especially the fact that you're not on
your computer or not on your phone not
doing anything you know your your
ruminating that's just lying there
thinking that's loops of negative
emotion you don't have any positive
emotion you know that's why you're not
on your computer or your phone and so
one of the characteristics of depression
I suppose two of the characteristics is
a decrease in positive motivation and so
that means that you're not interested in
anything and an increase in negative
emotion and that can manifest itself in
doubt just lying there thinking you know
so go talk to someone go talk to someone
tell someone that this is happening get
to your family doctor let them know
what's happening get them to give you a
depression screening and and see what
you can do about it because there are
effective treatments for depression and
sometimes antidepressants work like a
absolute charm